and what a treat to welcome back to the
Nixon Library in birthplace Larry King
Larry I don't think you're going to get
any argument from anyone in this room
that you are an undisputed genius in a
very very crowded broadcast field and
you stand out because you can talk to
anyone anytime anywhere on any subject
and I think all of you would be sort of
interested to get to know who's
listening for example when I was the
first time I was ever on Larry's show
Larry King Live was 87 we had a great
hour we had a lot of fun and my father
of course watched and the next morning
he got a phone call from the Prime
Minister of Canada Brian Mulroney Brian
Mulroney wasn't calling to talk world
affairs he was calling to talk about the
Larry King show Larry's the secret to
Larry success is that he really listens
and the other side of that coin is that
somehow he knows to ask the questions
that all of us who sit at home watching
would like to ask and yet he still
allows his guests to emerge with their
dignity intact and as real people now i
really liked his book anything goes i've
read it and what i thought was the most
interesting thing about it was his
comment on how politics has changed and
he makes the point that candidates today
are bypassing the networks and they're
bypassing the filter of network
correspondence and they're using
television they're using shows like
Larry King Live to get their views
across and as I read that in your book
Larry I had to think back to sixty eight
when my father made the incredible
comeback and got not the denomination to
run for president again because that's
exactly what he did he bought airtime
and he had a show he called in the arena
and he had a sportscaster name bud
Wilkinson who asked questions and then
they took questions from the audience it
was Larry King Live a few years earlier
the in the last four elections how many
of you have turned on Larry King when
you wanted to see a real debate between
candidates are just when you want to
listen to ross perot go now
hurry Larry's book is full of nuggets
and I love this turn of phrase quote
radio has always been a theater of the
mind but television is theater isn't
that true television is theater and
there then Larry went on his book to
talk about the 1960 debate between Nixon
and Kennedy and how he was listening on
radio and he gave Nixon the edge but
people who watched the debate on
television who didn't listen on radio
gave Kennedy the edge now the PostScript
though to that story is that the polls
did not remove one point so who really
knows who won but it shows that TV is a
different medium and it's a powerful one
in his book Larry also zeroes in on the
complaint that all of us here the
campaign's go on too long we hear too
much of it there are too many talking
heads and larry has a great response
he's just unabashed about about it he
says there can never be too much
political coverage in our democracy and
to that Larry all I can say is thank
goodness you make it interesting for us
because you are the man who can talk to
anyone anytime anywhere it's a great
honor to have you here with us today
thank
thank you thank you thank you really
nice to be back and it is me
you know there's a I i I'm in the Madame
Tussauds Wax Museum on forty-second
Street in New York and in Las Vegas and
I think they're opening one in San
Francisco was really weird to pose for
this thing I took about four hours and
they measure you and take pictures and
then when I finally saw it it was really
weird you know shizzle friend I really
weird cuz I'm standing like this with
the braces and it was like me you know I
was like I know what its gonna be like
to be embalmed I mean I was like was it
was bizarre and I it really is kind of
eerie and I have two young boys I'm 67
years old and I have a two-year-old son
and a one-year-old son and this is
without viagra this is uh and uh we took
them to Vegas a couple of weeks ago to
see their father I their father only in
this television magnetic modern world
could the father take the children to
see the father so we take them cannon is
going to be one years old at this time
he looks up like it's just another day
in a part give me a cookie but my
two-year-old looks at it touches it and
says it's a daddy doll I don't even why
I brought that up but I was just it's
really nice to be here a return visit to
be asked back to this auspicious place
I'm so impressed with this library and
the chance to do this special we taped
it this morning we went through with
Julie and I walking through the entire
library starting at the house where the
president was born ending up at the desk
he was sitting at when he suffered his
stroke and it was incredible and it's
going to air we think June twentieth
that's not locked in stone but it looks
like I'll be June twentieth but you'll
know of course based on all this
response you know you know I wear a
confession to make I don't know what dot
org is
no my wife is into it people are into it
I hate it I I don't understand it you
know I I like you know what i miss the
rotary phone good yeah remember that
phone it was wonderful you just heard
all the clicks you didn't get wrong
numbers no I miss that I'm i miss
there's a whole new thing out there you
may not have heard of it's called mail
no honest you to get his pretty little
stamp and you lick it and gets there the
next day you can wait I hate faxes I
hate fedex I hate modern things but I
know to what what resistance be like
without it anyway I know that will
devote a lot of time to questions today
this is such a homey wonderful group I
will tell you that I do a lot of
speaking I go all over the world
speaking I speak a lot to conventions
and get-togethers in large groups I've
spoken to 40,000 people at the Georgia
Dome in Atlanta it really is a thrill
it's great to get around to speak the
question I'm asked the most I'll get rid
of that right away is what was it like
to be kissed by Marlon Brando at the end
of our first interview for some reason
unbeknownst to me he just kissed me one
critic said that I kissed him come on
Oh a Jewish kid from Brooklyn we never
kissed a guy what he had of your mind
Sopranos would wipe us out anyway he he
just kissed me on the lips and I have
never been kissed on the lips by a man
in my life I don't know we're not
boasting you know I'm I'm heterosexual I
got nothing against your ah I'm just I'm
heterosexual I mention this everywhere
but San Francisco I don't don't bring it
up nothing oh so certain parts of Euston
I leave it out anyway he kissed me on
the lips and that's what people ask me
what was it like so I tell them you know
right i I've never been kissed my lips
my man I hug my brother I hug friends
i'm very affectionate but i do have a
confession to make and i'll make it here
at this library I can't stop thinking
about I it's weird I cannot start top of
a couple of weeks ago I got up in a
middle night yelling Stella and I don't
know anybody named Stella and I still
frankly you know i don't i don't plan
really what I'm gonna say and I still I
still pinch myself every day over
everything that's happened to me and
anybody in this business who's had
success and doesn't give a little credit
to luck and a little bit to pinching
himself as kidding him or herself cuz
I've been really lucky I mean when I was
a kid in Brooklyn I grew up and I would
listen to my radio and want to be on the
radio I wanted to be Arthur Godfrey I
wanted to be red barber and I dreamed
that I would be on radio and to have all
this happen to me to be on radio and
television and break-in in miami on a
very small station and suddenly find
myself on a network seen around the
world june first i'll celebrate 16 years
on CNN i still can i still can't believe
it i'm still that little kid from
Brooklyn meeting people like iced
interview President Nixon when he after
he had lost the governorship and came to
Florida did interviews with him on radio
interview him later on on television on
many occasions interviewed him we're
just set to interview Richard Nixon had
booked the date the day he suffered his
stroke which is really weird you know I
mean to have that happen because he had
just said okay and we had scheduled the
date and it was he
like just buzard to hear the news the
next day because he was a wonderful
guest he was always responsive and we
loved that and guess but I still can't
believe it I mean I'm i was in israel a
couple of years ago true story and it
still impresses me you know that I'm
seen around the world and I'm known
around the world and i'm standing at the
Wailing Wall the western wall and I'm
not particularly religious but it was an
emotional moment I was leaning against
the wall praying my brother was with me
and it was a wrap I there oh it Israeli
rabbi and he's praying severely and he
looks at me it says what's with perot
like like I couldn't believe it you know
and I've always looked her myself as
just this person with this inquiring
mind whose father died when he was nine
years old and who went to live with his
mother and his mother and brother and my
went to move to another residence in
Brooklyn we were on relief for a couple
of years life was pretty tough and I got
to all my dreams come true have them all
come true is still amazing to me and to
and sometimes you think you know that
when you got it all you think that
everything's really going your way you
can hit little trouble spots along the
way so you may be wondering what I was
going to talk about today it might
interest you to know so was I what am I
got so I thought it might tell you I do
this a lot in speeches if you've heard
them before I apologize but I feel the
warmth of this audience you may want to
know because this is technically a
put-down of me uh sometimes we can get
too big for our britches I I like to
speak because I like to meet people
here's your chance to get out among
people to see faces and this is a
wonderful audience in a very friendly in
a bright sunny day in a beautiful
atmosphere it gives you a great chance
but sometimes when you do that you run
into trouble is anyone here in rotary
are there any wrote Arians gentlemen
there anybody else okay good i could
tell this know and and now there were
ladies in rotary right used to be a
men's club only if you don't know what
rotary is basically do a lot of
volunteer they do wonderful work but
basically it's a hundred men white sox
brown shoes
they have lunch they sing rotary songs
they sell each other insurance they go
home this could be this could be New
Delhi or New York it's the same thing
with rotary clubs politicians who speak
at them know this wrote Aryans are just
a tunnel visioned and this is a true
story what happened to me I was in Miami
so I started my career and I was really
starting to make a name for myself and
to get a call one day from this guy says
I'm speakers chairman of the Miami
Shores Rotary Club he says mr. king we
are the oldest Rotary Club in America
Ponce de Leon was our first member we
are old I notices January but in June we
have our annual Rotarian meeting where
we invite the wives there were no women
members at this time it's a big meeting
and we'd like to have you speak so he
gives me to date and i said i'll be
happy to a wonderful Rotarian speech six
months away I write it down just as I'm
about to hang up he says oh by the way
what is your topic I said well I don't
have a topic I just speak
extemporaneously pieces I'm sorry you
have to have a topic I said I says this
is rotary he says if we invite president
eisenhower's what he said if we invite
president eisenhower we demand a topic I
said call him
I hung up he hung up next night i'm
about to go on the radio it's about one
minute to air time WI OD in Miami
producer comes in says emergency call
line one I pick up the phone and I hear
and it's this guy to speak is Jimmy says
I met the print shop we're printing up
the flyer for your meeting what is your
topic so i can tell if I don't say
something to this guy he's going to
drive me nuts and so I gotta say
something ladies and gentlemen this many
years ago to this second I have no idea
why I gave him this topic I knew nothing
about this topic I had no interest in
this town I had no guests coming to
discuss this topic but for some reason
still unbeknownst to me I said to him I
had to get on the air my my topic is the
future of the American merchant marine
swear to god he said thank you I said
thank you he hung up I hung up now I
thought nothing about it now it's six
months later all I have written down on
my calendar is like June fourteenth 8pm
Miami Shores country club I don't even
have rotary written I just know says
speech miami shores country club I have
no memory of this conversation I've done
radio television speeches newspaper
columns I just have no memory I drive to
the miami shores country club i get to
the parking lot there's a sign lot full
a park a block away and my ego is
carried away I'm just walking up saying
whoa wow man I packed him in I get that
affirmative building swear to god
there's a sign tonight the future of the
American merchant marine
I said to myself Jesus Christ they got
two speakers I got the wrong night
something's wrong right now the
speaker's chairman comes running out
this tells you a lot about rotary is why
i apologized he's beside himself with
excitement he said mr. King I'm so
excited this topic the future American
merchant marine broke broke their
all-time attendance record right they
came on wheelchairs from Fort Lauderdale
to hear this he says we are he says we
we can't wait to hear about the future
American merchant marine and I said to
myself you can't wait he takes me inside
the place is packed it's teeming and
they got me up on stage and it was just
unbelievable and this was really a
conservative Ruben I know I'm in
conservative country in Orange County
but this group the drummer wasn't in the
band I mean is this group was not
playing they thought the Revolutionary
War was treason no King George had a
point you know what I mean and they
threw the tea in the water and that was
a private property and had a big picture
on the wall of Barry Goldwater and on
top of said pinko I mean it is oh yeah i
think they handed out baby pictures of
rush limbaugh saying he is born I mean
it was weird anyway guy hit the guy gets
up the Chairman the guy who booked me
gets up to introduce me tells him he
took the day off work state farm
whatever he took the day off work he
went to the library to research the
history of the American merchant marine
since our guest is going to talk about
the future I might as well tell you
about the past and this guy does 20
minutes as I'm sitting there and he's
doing tonnage tonnage he's doing Harbor
size compared to tonnage I'm going to
sleep they're having an orgasmic
experience there will tear good there
might I never saw anything like it he
says in our ladies and gentleman to talk
about the future American merchant
marine Larry came
now that is Panik it's an example of
panic what do i do I got myself in this
fix I go up to the microphone they all
lean forward I talked for half hour and
never mentioned the American merchant I
figured if you don't know it leave it
alone right I spoke about politics I
spoke about Dade County I spoke about
sports I'm getting no reaction though
laughs no nothing I finally just said
thank you ran downstairs and ran out of
the auditorium I passed one guy turning
up his hearing aid you know did he
mention i get to my car get into carts a
jew night Miami's very humid start the
car at the air-conditioning's blowing in
my face I'm sweating and I'm saying to
myself I'll never speak again I don't
need this in my life you know I got
radio got elvers i could write I don't
need this and suddenly there's a banging
on the window of the car the speaker's
chairman from rotary has followed me to
my car and he is ticked no he's beyond
ticked he is in a new world of dictum he
has invented his and he's banging on the
window he's banging on window and foam
is coming out of his mouth is good I hit
the button the window goes down he's so
mad he sticks his head in the window he
got a picture this he's got his head in
the window and I got my hand on the bud
you know I'm a little Jewish kid from
Brooklyn you never know power right but
I could have sweated and guillotined him
right she backs off the window and he
screams you never mentioned the American
merchant marine you never mentioned the
future the American Marine we got the
largest membership in attendance in our
history I researched it we packed them
in we sent out the fliers and you you
never mentioned the future of the
American merchant marine I said they
have no future and drove away
another time another time I uh I i must
admit this i spoke for the Mafia um yeah
it's true I worked for the Mafia and you
know people watch the sopranos known to
get the idea my friend Mario Cuomo tells
me there is no mafia I said yes Marion
you're still governor anyway trust me
there is a mafia and like most of you
what I used to think was all the Mafia
did was muff all day long no I thought
they'd get up breakfast Krong Krong
Krong lunch Krong Krong Krong dinner a
couple of crimes go to sleep right
that's their business right we're in our
business they're in their business but I
found out they do other things they get
involved in charities they go to movies
they go to shopping centers their
children go off to war they get involved
in sports and they got involved in me
through charity I was a channel for in
Miami i'll never forget the name of the
guy who kissed a boy came in and said
Larry line one is for you it's a
boom-boom Giorno boom boom Giorno that's
a call you take right you take that call
I pick up I said hello that's the last
word I said voices king boom boom John O
War Memorial Auditorium Fort Lauderdale
Friday November third boys town of Italy
it's a charity sergio franchi is the
singer you are the MC eight o'clock
black tie hung up
I went something told me to go to this
some told me you'd be probably in my
best interest to go to this so i drive
up i got my tuxedo on I go up opposite
sears us one as war memorial auditorium
big sign tonight boys town of italy
sergio franchi singer Larry King mci
support thank God I wrote it down I park
I go into the special artists entrance
is a guy stand there dangling cigarette
double-breasted suit you know pinstripes
he goes I'm boom boom jano and we're
very glad you came and I said to myself
you're glad I came he takes me backstage
it was unbelievable yes sir joe with a
23 piece orchestra a cardinal from Italy
who heads at Boys Town a 50-piece
catholic high school marching band was
unbelievable i went over a sergio
franchi a wonderful singer I said how
they get you for this he says guy got in
boom boom giorno ho I'm here boom boom
gives you my instructions truth he says
to me go on stage to 20 minutes bring on
Sergio he'll sing for 45 minutes then we
come back on stage present the corner
with a check you can kid us all you like
we know your sense of humor you can do
italian jewish stuff we don't care but
please don't turn the house lights up
I says why not boom boom ease as well as
competitors in the audience just leave
it at that let's just say this guy's in
the jukebox businesses olive oil
business the whole section to your right
is FBI agents leave the lights dog so I
got on stage and they were really
wonderful I mean they take all responses
the Mafia there's a little pressure I
got a bit you know you want to do well
and tell you that so innately Afghan
everything I brought on Sergio he's
saying now we go back on stage we give
the cardinal or check for four hundred
and fifty thousand dollars I don't
forget handlings looking at that check
boy sound of Italy 450 thousand dollars
boom boom is now walking me to my car
and he's very happy with the evening
events he says to me we're very happy i
said my pleasure book bump he's a listen
I talked to her boys we are your favor
so I said boom boom thanks anyway I
happy to do it I don't need any favors
boom boom then says to me we don't like
to owe favors
so I'm not the smartest guy in the world
but I suddenly sense I have a mocker on
the Mafia and they don't like the old
favors right so I said to him what he
got in mind I swear I said what do you
got mine ladies and gentleman he said
five words I think of it now and I go
paralytic I I remember where the moon
was I remembered us the sweat going down
my you'll never hit us in your life I
you'll never hear these five words I'll
never hear him again but that night
outside the war memorial auditorium in
Fort Lauderdale about seven minutes
after eleven he said to me quote got
anybody you don't like
I'll tell the truth if you ever hear
that morality aside for a minute
somebody ever says that to you but in
the Mafia got anybody you don't like
first thing you think of his name's I
saved the life at a general manager
channel for that night I finally said I
said a boom boom I can't do that i
couldn't harm anyone and he was
disappointed you know visibly
disappointed and he said okay you're
like horse racing mr. Jace's we'll be in
touch two weeks later I get a call early
in the morning was a voice could have
been boom of honor who was it just said
apple tree and the third at Hialeah who
I had eight hundred dollars to my name I
borrow five hundred I run to the track i
bet 1,300 to win on apple tree as the
horses are going in the gate i say to
myself there are three sure things in
life death taxes and apple trees gonna
winter i especially knew her doing the
running of the race when five jockeys
jumped off their horses mafia has a way
of getting things done uh sometimes you
can speak mr. this the truth and and
great politicians notice and and and
eloquent speakers nose and it is nothing
to do with them it's more blessing of
God you can speak to a group and turn
them around by by the nature of a good
voice good expressions nice way to move
things on I mention Mario Cuomo's is a
great witty witty like mine eyes great
public speaker i saw him speak once to
the National sheriffs Association and I
said what you got a topic he says year
why I'm against capital punishment i
said mario the National sheriffs
Association
pick a different topic I don't I don't
think it's gonna work with this group
you know and he spoke and he got a
standing ovation he may not have changed
in the opinion but he really moved that
room with elegance and happen anyone's I
should is it true I get call one day by
the district attorney of Miami Dick
gerstein he says Larry got a real
problem we have two conventions in miami
beach at the same time same time
National District Attorneys National
Chiefs of Police just worked out that
way it's coincidence Sunday night the
fon durable ballroom is empty they want
to combine both conventions are ending
sunday a combined dinner and they asked
me to be the chairman and I agreed so I
had to cancel my afternoon session which
had Frank Sullivan chairman of the
Florida Crime Commission is the speaker
and he's going to speak at the evening I
said what's your problem he said would
you come over and follow him just do 10
minutes but follow him as a wisest he's
the world's most boring speak he's
Chandler to Florida Crime Commission we
all know it in Florida but this is a
national mr. National District Attorneys
National Chiefs of Police I can't be
embarrassed you follow him I said but
nobody knows me I'm just the local
personality said I'll give you a big
build-up big building they go there that
night I'm sitting on stage I'm scares
like 2,000 people's Chiefs of Police
some of them in uniform Frank Sullivan
gets up to speak the worst the worst
I've out he spoke like in a monotone he
had graphs yet shots yeah I mean I'm
gonna fight crime I think first person
to go to sleep was mrs. Sullivan she
went right into the Baked Alaska gone
boom he finishes sits down 20 minutes
the work longest 20 minutes half the
crowd is now standing up ready to go to
the elevators get out of that Sunday
night both conventions ending here's my
big introduction a late and Gemma before
you leave my friend Larry King
now take that his this instant I got
half the crowd standing they've just
heard the world's most boring speaker
that district attorneys and their Chiefs
of Police this is all instinct I ran
through the microphone ran to the
microphone I said ladies and gentlemen
hold it stop wherever you are I'm in
broadcasting yes broadcasting and I'm
proud of it and in broadcasting we have
a fairness doctrine we have an equal
time code we have just heard Frank
Sullivan speak against crime I am here
to speak on behalf of crime now let me
tell you could have heard a pin drop I
man i had them they sat down now how to
think of something to say right so I
said how many people by show of hands in
this room would care to live in Butte
Montana no I said see no hand went up
nobody wants to live in Butte Montana
the lowest crime rate city in the
Western world last year there were no
reported crimes in Butte Montana there
is no lock company in Butte Montana
Butte Montana is the safest city in
America nobody wants to go there that
top five tourist cities in America on
New York Chicago Los Angeles Las Vegas
and Miami the top 5 2 prime cities New
York Chicago Los Angeles Las Vegas in
Miami dot top 5 torus cities New York
Chicago Los Angeles Las Vegas in Miami
ladies and gentlemen crime is a major
tourist attraction
I guarantee you you get crime in your
community the airports are bulging they
got to build new runways people flock to
crime I said and another thing Sullivan
didn't tell you if you've got crime in
your area the money stays local they
don't tax that money the local bookmaker
goes to the local barbershop the flow of
money stays in the town and another
thing what if we listen to them what if
we follow all his graphs and charts yes
then what's happens will wipe out crime
in America okay then what everybody in
this room is out of work police chief of
Louisville Kentucky jumped up and said
what can we do to help
you are really a fun audience and okay
we've taught for 35 40 minutes now we'll
take some questions and I understand
this works John runs around with a
microphone is that anybody got a
question for buddy got a question if you
can't get there Mike just sing it out
but I don't care what you asked about
you could be personal I don't count on
it the answer I Larry have you ever been
at a loss for words when you've been on
the air with a guest been at a loss for
words I've never been at a loss for
words you know I'm a questioner and the
less you hear me the better if you turn
on my show nine out of ten nine and a
half out of 10 times the guests should
be talking if I'm talkin something's
wrong I don't do the show for me I do
the guest counts and I draw the guests
through me to you and all I am is that
curious interlocutor that rice ask the
best questions he can to draw them out
we r informational and entertaining at
the same time so it's not so much where
I don't use a lot of words I don't may I
don't have a soapbox I don't have an
agenda I've never had an agenda in my
life when I go on the I'm there to learn
like tonight we'll have a champion race
car driver on I'm going to be interested
in race car driving for now and ask the
best questions I can ask no matter who's
on or what the situation is I'm there to
learn and through me hopefully the I
never learned anything when i was
talking now sometimes did I to ever run
out of things to ask yet once Robert
Mitchum the late Robert Mitchum was the
guests and I loved Robert Mitchum as an
actor but he drove me up a Gazoo down
the tree and out the other side every
antsy gave me was one word and when you
get one word answers you run out of
questions you know I give an example he
did to me I said what was it like to be
directed by the great John Huston he
said seen one seen them all and then
leave me hanging just standing there you
know I kept going on and on on and on
finally I was asking what would you have
for dinner
the lady Michael my question is of major
political figures that you have
interviewed what traits of their
personality surprised you the most a few
examples to example traits that
surprised me the most well Richard Nixon
the first time I met and interviewed
Richard Nixon I I ear mite watched him
for years and I'd had up and down
opinions of them but I never knew how
smart he was he was the smartest
political figure I ever interviewed the
more easily I mean I would have hired
him in a minute to analyze any situation
in the world Richard Nixon had a way of
taking how did this how did how did the
situation give me the
israeli-palestinian situation right now
bring it up to date he would do 10
minutes he'd give me history give me the
day Ben Gurion sign this treaty who went
into here who marks there who marched
here who the leaders are Hootie
assistant leaders are who the real
leaders are you know everyone and
everything it brought it all together
for a concise fashion the most
surprising thing about well Ronald
Reagan I kind of knew that but what a
great storyteller he was Ronald Reagan
could remember asking him about what it
was like being shot and he took about
five minutes answering that and he
really made you feel like you could feel
that bullet I mean I you know I never
had that impression that that's really a
great quality that you can have that
quality cardo is his humanness I mean
Jimmy Carter Clinton said a lot you know
I feel for you but Carter really he was
a special and a great former president
great former President Clinton no I I
tell you know i'm i'm very impartial on
my show and i never tell people how i
vote and clinton is there is and i think
this is true he's the greatest enigma of
them all because he has so much smarts
and so much public ability and he could
work a room like nobody to work a room
yet there was that other side of him
that almost
I don't want to say dark side to side it
was almost boyish you know there's that
attitude of i was telling Julie Nixon
Clinton is like a guy we all had in our
life it's like your favorite uncle you
know the rest of the family used to say
he would uncle jim did but when he came
to your house he put five dollars in
your pocket and he gave you a wink he
said hang in there kid call me if you
get to town okay you know what I like
that about those saw he get an
extraordinary like look I one thing
about him was how much he loved the job
I mean you could like the job he loved
the job I'm ever standing with him we're
looking out on Pennsylvania Avenue and
he said to me my bad days of good days
my bad days are good days I told that to
Bob Dole and he said maybe I should get
out of the race now I wonder where
President Bush said to me once well and
if you Clinton one night and Bush the
next in the 92 campaign it was a wild at
the end of that campaign and Bush said
to me does he ever take a day off he's
relentless this whole life was getting
up in the morning on our politics who
else are we up to I never met I mean I
met John Kennedy once I wrote about this
little book issah never interviewed John
Kennedy but we miss a funny story we
were kids and I was a disc jockey in
Miami Beach I've just broken and I guess
we were 22 years old and we'd never seen
Palm Beach so four of us one guy had a
convertible and I drove it beat up old
convertible and four of us drove up to
see palm beach on the Sunday morning and
we're driving home is no one on the
street you know which is the quiet
Sunday morning like quarter of 10 people
I guess were going to church over and we
were driving up looking at the houses i
wasn't going more than 10 miles an hour
maybe five hours and hours wow look at
that look at her and suddenly I look up
and it's a guy in a convertible parked
at a red light and I hit him
boom and it's Senator John Kennedy of
Massachusetts and he gets out of the car
I can never forget this and he says how
it's a clear sunday morning i'm parked
at a red light there's two cars on the
road how could you hit me and i said
well i was looking up with nikki so I
said I'm sorry I said do you want you
want to exchange licenses say sis noises
but for you swear i'm gonna run hope for
me in 60 we swear next Larry truly enjoy
your show thank you and I was wondering
you have a multitude of guests but some
of them if I were they I would not come
on the show because some of the things
they have to talk about are really quite
embarrassing are they compensated or
paid in some way no no one on our show
is paid we'll fly people in will pay a
hotel room for the night no guest is
paid on talk shows the talk shows that
pay guess that one where there's music
and it's after involved so you paid if
you go on Letterman you paid on The
Tonight Show you're paid on Conan
O'Brien your and if there's a band
present the union rules require that the
guests be paid but like you're not paid
on the Today Show Good Morning America
or Larry King Live or any of any of the
talk shows your expenses will be
compensated if we fly you in some people
you know we have to deal with the
tabloid issues in life because tabloid
today has become intermixed with with
news and you know that the actor in
Robert Blake's wife gets killed that's a
story you can't not say that it's not a
story it's not oj simpson but it's a
story and it's drama and it deals with
life and death and sex and all the
things that people talk about when they
talk about things it's sad in a way that
that is where we focus but I would bet
that more people
would talk about the perversity of life
than about the arab-israeli situation
tomorrow morning in a coffee shop
somewhere and it's sad but it's it's
also true so good shows and we try to
stay at topic we try to cover the best
news and has diverse the way as we can
but last night we put on the young lady
who had a relationship with the FBI
agent that was arrested for being a spy
she said it was not sexual but he took a
paid her money she was a stripper a
hooker he liked her he gave her a car he
gave her an American Express card he
never slept with her I was fascinating
television I mean that's pretty
interesting now I I also did a show
maybe the most amazing show I've ever
done the most watched show I ever did
was perot-gore and I would
understandable because I mean that was
the heat of NAFTA and it was a debate
was watched all over the world but the
most incredible thing I think was when I
had the Ramseys on with the detective
who said that they did it and that was
weird man to sit there and this
detective pointed to her and said I
believe from all the evidence I
uncovered he was with the boulder police
you killed your daughter and you found
out about it to the husband and you're
covering up and she responded and then I
brake for commercial what do you do then
yeah I remember when / o called gore a
liar you are a liar we'll be back right
after this
so how is the weather today what do you
think you think these clouds are gonna
break you know what are you gonna bring
it up was it easy now anybody else Larry
yeah janet reno is reportedly
considering a run for the governorship
in florida and i'm wondering if you
could size up her chances well you know
I haven't lived in florida in a long
time I know Jana Reno forever I knew
Janet Reno when she prosecuted traffic
cases she was hired right out of Harvard
the one thing I'll say for Janet Reno I
you can think what you want about
turning gentle you couldn't buy her you
couldn't talk to her I mean you could
Clinton couldn't call her up and say do
me a favor you don't call up Janet Reno
and say do me a favor she may have made
mistakes you made a pluses and minuses
but she was not the kind of person that
you could she was a political in that
respect she was uh she has a bad case of
Parkinson's I don't see how she could
run I'm not in tune with Florida
politics they Jeb Bush is still ahead in
all polls that show against any when he
run against I think the last poll shows
with about a fifty four percent
popularity rating and I know Jeb Bush a
long time i doubt i can't see Janet Reno
as a governor I don't think that's her
kind of stick and she she has a severe
case of Parkinson's and I hope that's
the kind of disease that's regressive it
doesn't get any better I'd be surprised
if she did there there's a man named
Gary Aldridge who is a former FBI agent
who was metal to be on your show he was
what scheduled to be on your show during
the Clinton administration and for some
reason he was not allowed to go on your
show and I had heard that that there was
a call to your show from George
Stephanopoulos or someone from the
Clinton administration who asked that he
not be on the show and I wanted to ask
what influenced the Clinton
administration had on the guests who
appeared on your program none I know
I've heard that story I know he was
scheduled once and I think what happened
was not trying to refresh your memory
cuz I was out at a convention in sun
valley when that was going on and they
called me in sun valley and I know Gary
Aldridge was brookton any I think he
there was other guests it was supposed
to go on with him and he didn't want to
go on with them he said he was booked to
be on alone and they want their schedule
other people with him
but nobody has ever called ever called
to my knowledge now there are producers
and they deal with it all day long there
on the phone now talking to people but
I've never been told of anyone calling
our show I did to book anyone or a book
anyone yeah people call up and say I
recommend someone I've never heard
anyone say cancel this guess oh this
guesses book you shouldn't have them on
if it occurred I don't know about it and
knowing my producers in that staff I
would extremely doubt it you know you
hear things like this all time I've
never seen it happen for example one of
the most opinionated people i know is
ted turner and ted has become
extraordinarily liberal and
extraordinarily opinionated and I worked
for him for all these years and even
though he's not in power now at AOL Time
Warner he still the chief stockholder
but if he is he was the boss he ran to
show he never asked me to put on a guess
or take off a guest ever in fact one
night we did a show with Burt Lancaster
and Jimmy Stewart and on the show they
annihilated Ted Turner for colorizing
movies they killed him and I saw him a
couple days later and he says they
murdered I love them guys and they
murdered me I said well you knew they
were coming on yeah I knew you knew they
were gonna kill you yeah I knew you
didn't make any call I mean technically
you could have said they're off he's the
boss he runs the camera you never
wondered that that you know those are
stories that startled I am I have no
knowledge of that at all and would never
in my life would I cancel a guest who's
booked and I have total faith in the
staff but i'll ask further as i remember
was he didn't want to go on with someone
else yeah hi larry i enjoy your program
and i was fortunate to meet you in
angola Delphia the republican convention
a couple questions number one what do
you think will happen in the upcoming
elections will the Republicans control
the Senate and the house do you force
that is already we're talking about the
elections right I suppose and I think
most important of all I've maintained
for a long period of time that the
combination of President Nixon and Henry
Kissinger had
geopolitical view of the world that I
don't think any president before since
has had and I'd like your opinion I'd
agree completely with that the Nixon
Kissinger that was a we were fortunate
in my opinion that both you know we lot
of times in nation's history when a
nation gets lucky to you know luck plays
a big part in all our lives we were
lucky in World War two have Roosevelt
and Eisenhower and Nimitz and Halsey and
patent and Bradley all alive at the same
time Marshall unbelievable they live the
center we're very unbelievably fortunate
that Nixon and Kissinger were the same
generation and that he hired Kissinger
both as a secure is security of isin
Secretary of State very that geo
political view they looked at the world
they help they advance this world father
than any probably to Secretary of State
presidents ever as the first part it's
so close now it's too tough to call a
lot will depend on how the economy goes
to predict politics I'd say this I've
been around this game now I've been
interviewing people for 44 years you
know I get social security checks my
kids get so I hear I can't believe this
ah and to predict something to look this
far ahead I'll give an example you go up
to Richard Nixon in 1962 December and
you say he just lost for governor he
lost for president you're going to go to
Miami and New York going to be a lawyer
and be a private citizen six years your
president what would he a bet he may
have bet on it but no one else would
have bet on right he would have better
no one else would so so to try to
predict it what would happen is almost a
lot will depend on how the economy looks
you could have us you could have
something occur that changes the whole
picture you could have something
something go down the tubes you could
have a a jolt in people get out of work
in a massive unemployment you could have
a rise in employment you could have gas
prices you know if you're voting
tomorrow my vote against people all
politics is local
said tip o'neill he's right to forecast
it's so close now you got an evenly
divided Senate I'd have to break down
every race and look ahead at I can I can
almost predict you know that you can
become a national figure with Julie
mention television you can become giving
next present United States known by no
one in this room I could predict this
let's say the governor of North Dakota
anyone home okay I know what apologies
you know it's just not a famous state so
let's say it's governor joe shirt
governor joe sure governor North Dakota
no one knows them could be Republican to
Democrat don't matter no one knows there
is in Fargo a prison and the prisoners
are taken over they take over to prison
got all the guards hostage in the prison
in Fargo and they want to see the
governor the governor lands in Fargo's
couple of TV cameras there it's starting
to be a big story and the governor says
they want to say me I'm going in alone
no security with me no aids no PR I'm
going in to meet the prisoners and find
out the complaints Cabaye he walks into
the person now we're all there Fox is
there in CNN and CBS and ABC and rathas
there Jennings is there pro cost looking
down from the generation tablets and
he's there and we were all there were
Larry King lives that nerd and the
governor's there one day two days in
those days now we learn about his wife
we learn he was a Vietnam veteran he was
wounded he was a hero has the Purple
Heart his wife works in all of the clubs
he's got one kid that's mentally
[ __ ] but goes to regular school his
other little daughter is beautiful she's
kind of a beauty queen he's been in
there five days at the end of five days
he walks out with the guards free nobody
hurt comes to the microphone the whole
world's watching him he does this at
nine-twenty p.m. thursday night
I've learned a lot about crime in the
last five days and they'll all be
punished but I'm calling a National
Crime seminar right here in Fargo and
I'm asking all of our top law
enforcement officials to come here and
meet with people and learn how we're
working with crime and what could be
advanced in crime he's on the front
cover of Newsweek time US News and World
Report he's the next president nited
states and I already forgot his name
what name did I the King we have time
for one more question those other one
more about a closing comment and I'll
sign books and I gotta run to go to work
I saw Pat chase a jacked on your program
for week I didn't hear what I say I
sauce Pat Sajak yeah he's set in for me
for a week okay my question is are you
worried about your job
sir Sir spin the wheel uh-uh no I I like
that a lot I'm not I'm not I'm not
worrying a bit of a if he gets it fine
listen and we'll do you mean it sir have
you heard anything yeah we're in a very
confident business all of us have no
insecurities what you here sir why'd you
bring that up I'm gonna close i think i
made this request seven years ago and
they didn't listen to me please Julie
you have clout book yogi berra to speak
at one of these us have Yogi Bear his
what would happen yogi would come he'd
talk for half hour you don't look at
each other what is he talking about huh
what does he I don't understand this you
know why was he booked and then you go
home and a week later maybe two weeks
later you'll jump up and say yes and
you'll laugh and patty's yes he said
that you'll dictum because what yogi
does he speaks in fo rizzle he does not
know he's funny and everything he says
is totally true when you can have those
three things daily and Chicago had it
speaking aphorism not know you're funny
and be totally true it always kicks in
late so when you when he first said it's
deja vu all over again no one really
clicked in and said that don't mean
anything right okay here's something
yogi once said got it you got to think
about it yogi once said nobody goes to
that restaurant anymore it's too crowded
now to me that's genius I am I'm sitting
next to yogi one day up on a platform
marriott marquis in New York is a big
sportscasters dinner on the MC I'm
sitting between Garagiola and Berra
gradual and barrel longtime friends
gradual also a former player says to
yogi yogi what time is it and yogi said
swear to God do you mean now
that's a brilliant right Garagiola said
yes and he told him the time half hour
later gradual says to me when I asked
him what time did he say do you mean now
and did I say yes yogi was once asked
yogi if you found a million dollars what
would you do he said I'd find whoever
lost it if he was poor I returned it
immediately
he was on he was on a PBS show once no
one could figure out how he got booked
on PBS and the discussing philosophy of
life and they get to yogi what's your
philosophy said simple when you get to a
fork in the road take it my favorite
Yogi Berra story I'll close with this
was told to me by Gil McDougald a
teammate of yogi on those great Yankee
teams of the past yeah the great now to
David but they were great we do going
over a barrel one day and batting
practices Yogi's you hear the news on
the radio said what said today yogi
you're not gonna believe this but in
Dublin Ireland they elected a Jewish
mayor today yogi in Dublin Ireland they
elected a Jewish mayor yogi looked up
and said only in America thank you very
much thank you
thank you you wonderful thank you be
nice to Henry K